there is significant resistance tonight
to the coronavirus vaccine
getting it among one very important
segment of society
the u.s military many service men and
women refuse to take the shot for one
reason or another
some democrats now want the in
commander-in-chief to make vaccinations
mandatory for anyone serving national
security correspondent jennifer griffin
reports tonight from the pentagon
courtney walt billig's husband is an
army captain based at fort bliss
this dental hygienist mother of two is
young healthy and like many military
families was hesitant
to get the covid vaccine i know a lot of
my friends and
coworkers
were like i'm not gonna put that into my
body i i don't know what's in it
democratic lawmakers led by congressman
jimmy panetta
wrote a letter demanding president biden
order the military vaccinated before
600 thousand troops and their families
begin to move this summer to new bases
in the u.s and abroad
potentially spreading the virus second
shot correct
that is correct some republicans have
balked at a mandate
others say troops can't afford the
downtime if they get sick
one reason this military spouse got her
coveted shot
i don't want to have to worry about
being on con they go on contact traces
every time someone goes
and has coveted they have to be out for
two weeks this former navy seal got the
vaccine but says it should remain a
person's choice
if we force people to opt in that that
will not have as positive of an effect
on the other 324 million americans
that aren't in the department of defense
skeptics like staff sergeant kira
holbrook who worried the vaccine would
make her infertile
are coming around and getting vaccinated
at fort bragg
i've been talking to people who've got
the vaccine and they're pregnant now
i've talked to people who've taken the
vaccine and they're breastfeeding
and they broke down like the ingredients
and how it has nothing to do with that
so i'm comfortable with that now
one thing i really remember is
immediately after getting my
my shot putting my top back on and going
outside i was
i felt somewhat invincible hayes author
of never enough
says vaccine skeptics should be like
seals who are taught to think of team
teammate and then self we have an
opportunity to lead the nation
we need to see this virus as a national
security threat just as much as
any sort of foreign nation coming to
attack us on our soils
fort bragg has already seen a turnaround
in vaccine hesitancy since february
according to u s military officials
with 60 percent of those serving there
willing to take the vaccine
compared to thirty seven percent three
months ago brett
that's interesting janet one turnover
sees iran has been thumbing its nose at
the u.s before these negotiations resume
on a nuclear deal
saying they're going to enrich uranium
to a higher level now
another threat that we haven't seen for
a few years popping up from iran again
that's right brett three iranian
revolutionary guard
gunboats like these approached a u.s
navy and a coast guard patrol boat
in the persian gulf last night the armed
iranian fast boats got within 68 yards
of the uss firebolt which issued
warnings
in the dark over bridge to bridge radio
when those messages were ignored the u.s
warship fired shots and the iranian gun
boats fled we've just learned it's the
second time iranian gunboats
have challenged a u.s warship this month
alone brett
jennifer griffin live at the pentagon
jennifer thank you